so going back to the time that you were
in American Graffiti your motivation for
continuing with acting is it the same
back then as it is now no default mm-hmm
I mean the the work it was it was it was
always about the work I was raised in a
really good you know Mount Tamalpais
high school dan Caldwell College of
Marin where I met Robin Williams and
Harvey sesor and Jim Dunn they they gave
us great tools so when I did I never
promised you a rose garden and I was
pretty raw I didn't have a lot of
technique but you know when I was that
age it was more like oh wow you can you
can tell a story I can express I can
touch people in a certain way I didn't
really realize that when I first got
into it do you you know so so that was a
realization that was a discovery and how
long did that take
in terms of come to that realization to
that realization prob well I certainly
it came with with I never promised you a
rose garden it came fast and hard in a
way that I was not prepared for but then
once it all settled in I went oh okay I
could I could do this this is and
there's a lot to be learned here and
that's the other thing I was not good in
school I tried like hell but I was not
good I was very dyslexic without knowing
yet I think a lot of actors are and it
was a great education for me you know
it's a great way to learn about
something and especially to express it
in a certain way it made it really stick
whatever it was that I was studying
you